it's 8:00 in the morning by the canal
saint-martin in Paris for what he has to
use this name to remain anonymous is a
migrant from Pakistan and he's camping
out on the sidewalk that's against the
law but he has no other option for WOD
lives in constant fear that the police
could come back and take away his few
possessions again we have two sleeping
bags and a one blanket but it's not
enough the ground is cold and the cold
is coming from the ground so you feel
too much cold you cannot sleep well
sometimes my friend wake happens and
sometimes I wake up here but it's not
good for us and night was terrible
his first port of call is a private aid
organization he's hoping to get
something to eat but mostly all that's
on offer is a cup of tea served by local
residents for Wat sleeps close to the
building where migrants are registered
the organisation tear disease has been
put in charge of this process the
Association was originally set up to
fight for the rights of asylum seekers
but the director rejects the idea of
providing temporary shelter inside
I don't know any space inside I can't
just let in 300 people I have a
responsibility to protect my employees
that would break safety rules and it's
not allowed the watch spends the rest of
the morning waiting he wants to take a
shower in a public bath but there's
already a long queue outside he gives up
today he'll have to go without washing
but despite such abject living
conditions the stream of migrants
arriving in France continues to grow
more than 110,000 are estimated to have
come in 2016 their favourite destination
is Paris for Wat is not the only one who
first wanted to go to Germany and then
decided for France he had heard that
everyone gets residency here if they
wait long enough
the Germany is good for the refugees at
first place they will accept that they
will give proper shelter they will give
proper food good money but they won't
give you papers they will just say to
you that now you are lying just go away
and then they will send you back to your
country I didn't know I heard it from
the other fellows on the way that the
French are not sending the people back
and they are opening their doors to
refugee the number of deportations has
fallen in France ahead of next year's
presidential elections Francois Hollande
center-left government appears keen to
avoid making headlines that could be
unpopular with left-wing voters by the
afternoon for why it still hasn't had
anything to eat he hadn't expected to be
simply ignored here from time to time
for wife considers returning to Pakistan
even though he says he's frightened of
the Taliban there because he worked for
an IT organization which also trains
young women that was in the Pashtun
region close to the border with
Afghanistan there they were shooting
directly on me but thanked thanks to God
that I had a car and they were on foot
so I escaped and then they threatened me
again with the letters and
as they can do that's threatened me so
my father suggested that I should leave
the country as soon as possible
his family sold a lot of land to pay for
Fawaz Passage to Europe he set out full
of hope six months ago people smugglers
took all his money now he's in another
line to try and get an appointment with
the authorities sometimes he waits all
night his hope has dwindled your mind
get twisted and you you think that the
dying is much easier than this because a
worse life is worse than dying
and if you get die you will a you
Electress at least rest in peace but
here it is not life it is worse than
death no one really wants to take on
responsibility for people like followed
the influence of the far-right from'
Nacional is too strong the party with
its constant anti-migrant rhetoric is
now one of France's strongest political
forces tear disease is feeling
overwhelmed first have to register as
asylum seekers but the prefecture only
gives us a contingent of 80 appointments
a day we have 250 to 300 people arriving
here each day we don't know what to do
with the people it's an impossible task
Papa CBO in the evening for wat heads to
the railway station in search of food
but when he arrives the residents who
normally hand out food aren't around
I think we will sleep hungry tonight
so no food for tonight and we are out of
luck because tomorrow at the breakfast
place we are not serving proper
breakfast we will just have a tea our
camera team buys for what a few packets
of food so that he's got enough for
tonight at least
neither rejected nor accepted the wad
has ended up in limbo land like so many
other migrants arriving in France